wenn du jemanden beeindrucken willst
dann macht dieses Safran Risotto wir
beginnen mit den confierten Tomaten
dafür haben wir halbierte
Cocktailtomaten dazu Rosmarin Thymian
Knoblauch Zucker wir geben Olivenöl
drüber und ab in den Ofen bei 180 Grad
jetzt ist unser Risotto dran Einstich
Butter in unseren Topf wenn die Butter
geschmolzen ist geben wir fein gehackte
Schalotten dazu die dünsten wir einmal
schnell an und dann gehen wir auch schon
unseren Risotto Reis dazu wenn der Reis
angeschwitzt ist löschen wir ab mit
einem Gläschen Weißwein ich finde dafür
dass Risotto wirklich schon Gericht von
uns Risotto gemacht geht es viel
einfacher als man denkt Gemüsebrühe
drauf geben und damit das Ganze auch
wirklich fancy ist geben wir ein
bisschen Safran dran einfach so paar
Fäden Sachen hat so einen starken
Geschmack den gesamten Kochprozess habe
ich auch mittlerer Hitze gehalten nach
15 Minuten in unsere Cherrytomaten so
aus und ich sage euch das sind
geschmacksbomben jetzt bisschen Parmesan
drin und wirklich alles rauszuholen was
an Cremigkeit geht unterrühren
guckt euch das an
boah der ist überhaupt